all right the time being 1005 call this
meeting the order for the house
representatives osborne patusik and
mcaleer for the senate
uh senator french
and of course uh the esteemed john hunt
is with us here in in spirit over the uh
over the interweb hi john
we love you john miss you
um so i have an amendment that uh i have
passed out this is uh 2022 2070h
have you all had a chance to look at it
do you have anything you want to say
i do
okay i want to thank you very much for
coming up with this language that we can
all accept i talked to senator carson
and senator cavanaugh
and they as well as myself are very
happy with it all right well i'm here to
serve
how does the house feel
okay all right well also the the senate
accepts house amendment and uh with that
uh
do we accept the bill as amended
we do we do all right i will have
someone who knows how to do such things
right up the report thank you very much
you